International leaders including German
Chancellor Olaf Schultz are meeting
today in Berlin to discuss rebuilding
Ukraine the conference was opened a
moment ago by the chancellor and by
European commission president Ursula
fonderlein with Ukrainian president the
loudimir zielinski joining via video
link to address the participants
conference organizers say that
reconstruction is a quote generational
Mission and a key step toward Ukraine
joining the European Union
it is estimated that hundreds of
billions of Euros will be necessary to
rebuild the country
Germany's chance the Olaf Schultz
pledged his country's continued support
Victoria
and that it is never too soon to tackle
this task
now is the moment to convene the
brightest and best Minds to provide
expertise and recommendations to start
rebuilding Ukraine
now is the moment to use the world's
Collective knowledge to contribute to
Ukraine's future
now is the moment to develop the
institutional framework to govern and
deliver Ukraine's reconstruction
and now is the moment to discuss how
Ukraine's future can be built and
financed
and let's bring in DW Chief political
correspondent Nina haza tell us a little
bit more Nina about the messages that we
have heard to kick off this conference
as the current head of the G7 so the
most industrialized democracies around
the world and he said this is not a
donor's conference we're not here to
make more pledges for financial support
what we are here for is to discuss what
kind of a framework do we need how can
all the various International
organizations come together and help
Ukraine and recover and reconstruct
itself and also modernize itself this is
why he doesn't want a carry the
character of a political meeting he's
brought in people from the World Bank
from the IMF from the ebrd from the
European Investment Bank they're all
going to sit down together and look at
some of the proposals that are on the
table but also discuss can we reach some
sort of an agreement that we set up
something similar to the Ramstein group
where of course International Partners
International allies of Ukraine sit
together and coordinate what kinds of
weapons deliveries can come from which
country how can we set up something
similar in terms of financial solidarity
with Ukraine but of course there are a
lot of very sticky issues here to touch
absolutely one of the stickiest issues
uh Nina is the fact that the fighting
continues on the ground of course so
tell us a little bit more about the
timing of of what
um you know these uh influencers and
leaders are planning right now and
whether or not the outcome that they
desire is indeed realistic
well they've all stressed the fact that
Ukraine is the one that needs to be in
the leading role Ukraine needs best uh
knows best what it needs but of course
Ukraine has already said that it needs
roughly some 750 billion dollars in
terms of re-building its country and um
there is something here on the table
where um politicians are going to have
to to stay realistic as well they are
going to have to look at can we really
for example use Russian Russia's frozen
assets like the Ukrainian president
demanded
um for reimbursing Ukraine for some of
the war damages that have been caused
now what's going to come out of this
meeting is not going to be some sort of
a international or political paper but
they are going to pull all the experts
recommendations and this is just the
beginning of a very long process but
this is one of the messages that's
coming out from here already as well
well we're only starting this process
but we have to start it now because we
can't wait for the war to be over
because Russia has very clearly
formulated the goal of destroying
Ukraine as a country making sure it
doesn't exist anymore and of course the
Western allies have the completely
opposite goal they want Ukraine to
recover and remain a livable country and
in order for that to happen they say
reinvestment needs to happen now but one
of the questions they need to discuss
here is how can we get private
investment to go back into a country
where you're at risk of losing all your
investment because of Russian bombs and
where so much Aid is needed indeed right
now uh president zolenski underscoring
the urgency of the Navy said he says
that it's needed for the country's
survival
um you know Nina this is also coming
against the backdrop of relatively tense
German Ukrainian relations lately
Germany says that it will continue to
send air defense systems to the country
but of course Ukraine has been calling
on Germany for more including sending of
Tanks
how far can this conference go right now
to amend what has been a relatively
tense relationship
well it is definitely one of the
attempts to help uh soften those
tensions between Germany and Ukraine
that is something that is very clear in
here in political Berlin that the German
government feels it is sometimes
misrepresented because of course when
you look at humanitarian aid financial
assistance Etc coming from Germany to
Ukraine that has been quite substantial
weapons deliveries is a very very
difficult topic here Germany broke with
lots of its taboos and by sending
weapons to Ukraine in the first place
into a crisis region with an active war
going on that is not something that had
ever been happening so Germany is making
a lot of is going through a lot of
change itself but definitely all I've
thought is sending this message to
Ukraine you can rely on us for all other
things you we are delivering weapons we
will also deliver three more assist air
defense systems next year and we're
doing this sort of a ring exchange where
we are supplying our partners with
modern weapons and they can then send
weapons to Ukraine in exchange for that
so that is going on that there is one
concrete example with Greece that is
going to be announced uh later on uh
this month and this is something where
Germany says we are standing by your
side and we are tackling this issue from
very very different angles
Chief political correspondent Nina haza
thank you
foreign